this program is brought to you by Emory
University well we have two co-directors
of the Urban Health Initiative dr.
Charles Moore and dr. J Debussy Jones
and we also have several others or
senior faculty advisors dr. bill Sexton
dr. Michael rich and dr. Nadine Kaslow
and we came together and one of the
first things that happened was dr. Morse
said come out and see what we're doing
and so I did and I said oh it looks like
you don't have enough garden space and I
know someone who's involved with
aquaponic farming can we bring them
together so we did in the city of
Atlanta came because they said the kind
of goals that you have or the same sorts
of goals is our sustainability division
so if you can do something in the
sustainability area that helps to meet
the mayor's goals then we can partner
with you so it's sort of organic asking
people who has interests I've been now
going to faculty members and saying do
you have residents medical students grad
students and public health nursing who
would like to come out and work in this
area and I'm thinking well we need a
partner in the business school because
if we do well with the aquaponic farming
and we do what we mean to do which is to
really help people move out of poverty
then we also have a partner with
Tuskegee and fact Tuskegee has gone as
far as naming the city of Atlanta as a
sister city so and it's Atlanta does not
have a sister city in the United States
yet they do have it in other countries
so we're working to see if it will also
become a partner with Tuskegee and dr.
Moore has the concept of urban to rural
so if we can make this work well in our
area Tuskegee has similar problems but
even greater poverty so we would get the
School of Business
faculty and students together to help us
see if we could sort of package it as a
franchise and move this concept to other
places in the city here as well as
Tuskegee and to other places in the
country
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University